[Music]
this is an important conversation we
need to have let's talk about body hair
a lot of men with melanin we have dark
body hair so it's important when you get
to your hotel room i bring a beer
trimmer
and also a body trimmer
this is the beard trimmer the philips
norelco beard trimmer you can adjust the
height of your beard it's really clutch
what you see right here on me right now
is a 1.5 or a 2. and this is the
manscape and i just like to keep it
super tight you know what i mean now you
may be asking why don't you do both
trimmings at home i am married and i
have my wife and we share a bathroom i
like to treat hotel bathrooms the same
way the united states treats its foreign
policy i'm gonna get up in there
i'm gonna make a mess
and then i'm gonna walk out and act like
it was never my fault this is laquinta
inn's problem
[Music]
you know operating out of a backpack
this is kiehl's blue herbal spot
treatment that's for pimples kiel's like
a a company i feel that as a guy from
the midwest who doesn't pay too much
attention to the way he um looks it
feels like i'm not too far off this
feels like being a grown-up and being
responsible and like this and the face
scrub
that's about that's about that's about
what i do
and that's that's that
my third essentially gonna be that late
labo i like to move around with
different fragrances one of my newer
fragrances that i just got put on my
bait put me on this pretty much it's
cool because
like when you when you're getting it
made you facetime me like they literally
like making it in front of your face
like there's not nothing that you're
just gonna buy out of the store they
literally making this in front of your
face and it's like real personalized
like on my bottle
bay wrote on there rock big daddy energy
no kids yeah but it's a good fragrance
that stick with you all day
this right here is number 25 you know
what i'm saying
they got different levels levels
[Applause]
[Music]
hydrating argan oil mask this is a good
cutting move for you guys at home anyone
who like bleaches their hair [ __ ] with
their hair a lot i bleach my hair a lot
and
i'm in the ocean a lot so it gets all
like dark brown
like frizzy you know like christopher
lloyd and back to the future so you just
start it after you surf or take a shower
and then you leave it in and you're good
to go that smells good and it leaves you
feeling like silky smooth you know can
you like mime how you would apply it
no dude i'm not doing that
you do it
[Music]
lip
gloss
oh my god it smells so good and i
usually have like a lip gloss or
lipstick or whatever matches with
whatever i'm wearing that day so today
it's this
these are pomades
now if you've ever seen or read the
outsiders you understand pomade is very
integral to life on the streets this is
a sleek water light pomade by frederick
benjamin i'm pretty sure this is like if
you're going to the grocery store really
quick you don't need anything too thick
you might be right back home because
it's not lasting that long but it's not
that heavy you know it's good for your
porsche
this is american crew grooming now this
is kind of thicker it's almost like a
petroleum like gasoline type of thing
this is what they use before they flick
the razor blade this is what fonzie had
this will last you all day maybe two
days but the integral part is the scotch
porter hair bone you throw this on the
bottom really get the waves going really
make sure they stay in place i got a
cowlick then i got a weird hair pattern
to grow like that you know like that so
like i gotta make sure it's laying flat
or i'm gonna look like i'm balding and
there's a lot of people missing here
these days i don't want to be one of
them so make sure you know if you're
losing your hair cut it against the
grain get it one low or just be bald
don't embarrass yourself
next up
we got tom ford exfoliating scrub and
this is a lifesaver for me so playing
john b is great but i naturally have a
little bit of facial hair so i have to
wake up every morning and shave my face
and i use this probably twice a week and
it immediately brings my skin back to
life it helps me so much with small
breakouts i do have sensitive skin so
this is a
go-to lifesaver
thank you tom ford
cocoa butter i can't go nowhere without
this i'm dark skinned so
i don't like lotion lotion don't do
nothing for me it's too thin cocoa
butter is thick and it feels good on my
skin and it makes me look good i always
use cocoa butter but i think this brand
parmesan i've been using for years and a
long time
i love palmer's you know these the
little ones like at home i had a big
jars and all the probably like two of
the bathrooms and all of my book bags i
always have
a little jar
i love the smell i like the texture of
it i like everything about it it's just
cocoa butter does body good
[Music]
this is essential for me too
my pintura my nail
paint in my nails i have a little dot in
every one of them like i used it once to
remind myself
of like i love the the poetry in the
image of god creating us from the dust
you know from the floor from nothing
like from nothing special at all and
it's exactly the the spirit the
breathing the rua they say in the hebrew
culture the rua that made us unique and
special but it's a beautiful reminder
that yes we are divine but yes we are
nothing dust and that's a reminder of
that and i used it once and when i tried
to
take it out
like i felt like naked like when you're
lacking something like oh my god i need
this and i did it again and since that
moment
like three years ago
i haven't stopped and my hands are all
the time
in camera in the scene in the guitar
in the spot you know and i want every
little detail and corner of my person to
share a message you know
[Music]
some days whenever up there you have to
cover up some things that you don't want
people to see
so get something like this to try to
make up something that i i've screwed up
the night before partying too hard or
maybe just living a life of dream a
luxury when i was a kid my sister they
dressed me up in makeup dressed women
women's clothes and stuff like this so
in the 90s i just brought it all back
you know but it was my preference it
made me happy made me feel good made me
feel free this is like
a savior to a lot of people around the
world i mean men women actors
entertainers
athletes you know you name it this
foundation it saves a lot of people's
lives and guess what thank god i found
this guy years ago thank you foundation